okay so tell me about these a sparse
okay what do you want to know how she's
legal there right yes it's legal but it
ain't a hundred percent legal I mean you
just can't walk into a restaurant roll a
joint and start puffing away I mean they
want you to smoke in your home where
certain designated places those are hash
bars yeah it breaks down like this it's
legal to buy it it's legal to own it and
if you're the proprietor of a hash bar
it's legal to sell it it's legal to
carry it but but but that doesn't matter
cuz get a lot of this all right if the
cops stop you it's illegal for them to
search you I mean that's a right the
cuffs and amsterdam don't have oh man
I'm going that's all there is to it a
[ __ ] going I know baby you dig it the
most but you know what the funniest
thing about your up is yes it's the
little differences I mean they got the
same [ __ ] over there that we got here
but it's just just there it's a little
different example wow you go up into a
movie theater and buy a beer and I don't
mean like in no paper cup I'm talking
about a glass of beer and in Paris you
can buy a beer at mcdonalds and you know
what they call a quarter pounder with
cheese in Paris they don't call it a
quarter pounder with cheese no man they
got the metric system there they
wouldn't know what the [ __ ] a quarter
pounder is what they call it they call
it a royal oh geez Royale with cheese
yeah that's right well they call a Big
Mac well Big Macs a Big Mac but i'll
call it love big mac letting mac what
did he call a whopper I don't know I
didn't go into burger king well you know
what they put on french fries in Holland
instead of ketchup what may
god damn ah i see them do it man if i
can join him in that [ __ ] yuck
you